okay we're back here on overtime Martin
Short what was your favorite SNL
character to play um I would say that
was Nathan Thoreau
I love me Nathan Thurman the defense of
the month that we need him now ever more
[ __ ] I know that I know that I don't
think I know the cigarette that is
always huh you know I was another thing
I was amazed that in your book I didn't
know that you only did one season on so
night life I had one night contract I
mean you were so good and made such an
impression I thought you were on there
for like five years
that grimly for Halloween you were
absolutely my mom's trying to find a
picture for me to bring but seriously I
must say so you still got the uncanny
hiccup you still go out for Halloween
this is some time ago so three years ago
how much candy okay come on
okay uh were the recent elections Jeremy
in Afghanistan legitimate or was it
rigged by America to ensure that the
most viable puppet would win ooh I
wouldn't go that far I mean I think I
don't think they were free and fair
elections um there are ours large right
now there are ours large swaths of the
population don't vote the Taliban do
ours
right exact no I'm to pay the Taliban
still control their parts of the country
so do ours I mean do you know that the
the u.s. helped to create an epic mess
there and at the end of the day we're
gonna leave the Taliban are still gonna
be strong the place is going to be
largely unstable and and there will be
some sections of it that are much better
off than they were under the Taliban
if after 9/11 we had done nothing but
enforced the cockpit doors and increased
airport security wouldn't we be better
off yeah yes yes oh I'll let me yes
you got eight million kids in school in
Afghanistan now you've got a majority
the population that has access to
education health care basic services
that they didn't have access to before I
mean actually understand is you have you
a way we're a big Afghanistan eight
million kids in school okay but first
first of all first of all there's a huge
dog and pony show going on I don't know
if you've been to Afghanistan but I have
multiple times there's a huge dog and
pony show going on in Afghanistan where
they'll take members of Congress
they'll take political figures they'll
take human rights organizations and
they'll show them this sort of green
zone that they've built where all of
that is true you step outside of it or
you remove the occupation forces
guarding it and the whole thing crumbles
back to where it was yeah you know it's
just because you've been Afghanistan
mister you know Jeremy I have an Afghan
at the end of my bed and it makes me as
much of an expert but okay all right
well we don't like to believe we can't
make things better it's against the
American rule by right it's like to say
we what how much we want to do what if
we can't do something but it that goes
back to the Greeks that's Western man
Eastern man is more accepting you know
that's the yin the yang thing whereas
the Western man thinks he can change
fate that's in a lot of Greek plays this
isn't just changing fate this is like
changing an entire other culture you
don't understand I mean right the one
thing I I've gotten from bets come back
from Iraq Afghanistan I've talked to a
little bit as it they're under no
illusions but almost all of them tell me
you know we knew this [ __ ] was gonna
happen as soon as we left right we
understand there was nothing was really
taking root here right uh we were doing
I'm in some ways I think their
sacrifices are more worthy because they
knew when they were doing it it wasn't
gonna work right but they still did it
and risk that life nobly and honorably
yes if you ever want to be we this
country will not be can't acknowledge
that it lost two wars and it can't
acknowledge that that means that we
cannot start fighting another [ __ ] one
in the same place and expect a different
result
and that if you really want to change
your culture you have to spend a hundred
years there yes not ten that's just not
gonna work and even then you look at the
British Empire yeah there for a hundred
years and they end up being is affected
by where they are as affecting them well
it's a two-way street you know the
failure was in the well there were so
many failures but the the place is where
we've had these successes right if you
look at after World War two you have a
German occupation that lasted until now
we still have troops in Germany we still
have troops to police in Japan but these
cultures did change and modernize and
become a mother to begin with it wasn't
like Germany had to come up from where
Afghans members of a civilized
globalized world that's what you're not
really impairing Germany with
Afghanistan or no no no what I'm saying
bill is I think what I think what Andrew
was saying and I think to your point
it's that you know we we can't change
these cultures overnight we think we can
but sure as hell if we're going to we
have to stay and commit and be there
right don't even have to change these
cultures I mean that's helped change the
path well can we help - Japan hook well
let they're throwing acid in schoolgirls
faces that's not changing culture but no
no that's confronting people who are
despicable criminals who would do
something like that that's not actual
there's no coal but it is it isn't where
you know Billy is your turn to throw
acid at your sister for not wearing the
hijab I mean that's just not that's okay
but it's not just a few people who
believed no and it's all and it's also
not just a few people who were shooting
people in the face and Afghanistan and
waterboarding people I mean there's
there there there are massive crimes
that are committed in the name of
religion across the board we didn't talk
about but you were talking about a
little bit about why people think you're
Jewish but I mean the fact is are the
fact that Israel's our client state is a
big part of our problem unless - unless
we sort of reset how we approach that
area of the world nothing's gonna
fundamentally change
well Obama veto the bill that passed in
the House today directing the government
to move forward on the Keystone XL
pipeline yes of course a well as he
should wait will he will he veto will he
veto the they passed the Senate passed
the Keystone pipeline the House passed
the Keystone pipeline and distend
probably will in the next Congress and
then he will veto it okay he probably
will I think I think it's more why would
why would he veto it though I mean it
actually a little because we're putting
some but what's really other than the
atmosphere we want to live it's a very
divisive issue why are you the wife it's
amazing very divisive issue on his own
side the labor is totally for the
Keystone pipeline so it I mean it's not
like I mean there is but in a certain
point if you're president for almost
eight years can't you just go with what
is right and what must be done he's like
yeah yeah and he absolutely what's he
got to lose
yeah if it is it right to create jobs
but you know for their content or what I
tell ababa jobs
I thought we hated socialism is it that
the government should always be the
people who are funding a jobs program
I thought we hated that I thought we
were the people who pull ourselves on my
rely on our own natural resources and
not on the resources of dictators I want
to rely on on renewable energy just care
it takes time you have a transitional
picture on our own energy resource it
takes charge when a party is completely
bought off by the extraction industry
that's what takes time yeah I mean
there's absolutely no reason
as I said to REM wall you know changing
technologies creates jobs if you guys
didn't get all your drive money from the
oil cup I'm not ready today like it's
you know we you're not ready ten years
ago they weren't ready twenty years ago
it's like no we haven't officially okay
we'll love you very well with natural
gas even Naturals Renaissance happening
in this country and that's actually
where huge jobs are being created that's
that's really where I'm not by the
president want oh wow that's not
non-carbon either I think we I push the
envelope as far as we can push it I mean
you believe in global warming right and
surely and humans are contributing to it
I get it
oh we're bidding good game conduct the
count the cows that contributed casual
yeah that's human you know why that's
why we have so many cows you talk about
the 40 right right yeah methane yeah
that I am I mean it's a big deal people
giggle but yeah yeah it's rich it I'm so
glad I'm miss gray on Oh for the cocoa
come to an agreement on cow farting is
something we have to turn our attention
to thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen